hi guys this is luca from cucanapedo.com
and today i am with a wonderful guest to
goals by the name of gabriel gabriel
from spa health we're here in warsaw the
weather is a little bit gloomy but it's
actually the perfect opportunity to
shoot a video for you guys so without
further ado let's talk about today
today's video topic so today we're going
to talk about
five things that polyglots do
differently when it comes to learning
techniques and mind you this is a part
of a video series about how polyglots
learn differently so
please check in the description box
there's a link to a video that we've
made together about a mindset this time
and it's going to be and it is actually
on gabriel's channel
so let's dive right in so point number
one is that one thing that i think
polyglots do differently is that they
find and possibly build their own
language learning material deborah
what's been your experience what do you
think about this point yeah i always
search for language learning material
that works best for me because what's
important is that the language learning
material that you have is a bringing you
success and b is fun because
there's so much material out there and
some of it is super boring and might be
interesting to others and others boring
to other people so for me it's really
important that it's fun that
i like the topic for instance listening
to a podcast where the narrator speaks
about something that is interesting to
me or i love watching netflix series and
movies and
it's about something fun so i enjoy the
process
but i happen to do it in another
language so that's all material for me
that that helps me to to be successful
with the language and i have fun at the
same time so it's really important for
me to find the things that that are fun
for me that work for me and sometimes it
might take a while
sometimes i start with something and
it's fun at the beginning but then i
start not enjoying it so i know i have
to change it but i always think my to
myself is that material the right
material for me right now do i learn
with it and am i having fun with it so i
think that gabriel really hit the nail
on the head when he said that for
example he asked himself is this
material enjoyable now because your
level evolves right your skills in the
language evolve so something that is
cool right here or right now might not
be cool uh i don't know three months
down the line so keep that in mind
because your skills evolve also the
language learning material has to evolve
and then the other thing is that you
have to invest the time invest the time
in finding one or two resource resources
for you that work at that specific time
because it makes a difference instead of
just doing what most people do and it's
just like downloading a bunch of apps
and then using a bunch of platforms and
then books and then you think that the
more you have the better but it's not
actually
that way it doesn't work that way so
focus on a couple of resources think
thoroughly about
whether these resources are challenging
and enjoyable at the specific level that
you have and then
always remind yourself that your skills
evolve and you might and will change
resources over the course of time yeah
and simplicity is really important here
like you said it's better to have a few
resources
that that you like that that work for
you than having tons of them and losing
sight and then losing motivation because
you can't just follow up on all of them
and and speaking of which the fact that
you know talking about the paradox of
choice the more choices you have to make
the more tiring it is imagine you wake
up in the morning and say okay i have
this app this book i have these notes i
have this and this and then you have to
decide and you already lost 10 minutes
and your energy is already down the
drain so think about that because it
makes a difference okay having fantastic
resources that are enjoyable and
challenging for you is fantastic it's
necessary but it's not sufficient
i always say that it's more important to
focus on systems rather than goals
what's what's your take on that
yeah definitely you have to find a
system that works for you and sometimes
it might take a bit of experimenting but
once you have that system you have to
follow it because
having a goal is really important that's
what you're working towards and having
milestones in between is important too
but you don't see any results from day
to day so if you learn today and
tomorrow you won't see any results on
day three and that might get you
discouraged so if you focus too much on
the goal getting closer to that goal
feels on a day-to-day basis really slow
but rather if you have a system
and you know that that system is what
will eventually get you to a goal and
you just have to follow that system you
don't think about it every single day
you don't create friction thinking about
what can you do today what can you do
tomorrow but you set up a system and you
follow it every day it's like it becomes
second nature to you you you do it like
you have that routine that other daily
routine where you brush your teeth where
you take a shower if that if you have
such a system when it comes to language
learning then you'll make massive
progress and you will get to your goal
you know it reminds me of a student of
mine who was desperate to learn uh
english as fast as possible he kept
asking me at every single coaching
session when am i going to get fluent
when am i going to get fluent you know
the the the the donkey trek when are we
gonna get there what am i gonna get
there are we there yet are we there yet
the thing is that um you know language
learning is a long journey and and the
thing is like when you try to learn a
skill or bring about a major change in
your life that's for example you want to
lose weight if you look at yourself in
the mirror every single day you will not
notice a change day by day so you have
to be confident of the fact that the
process is working for you but most of
all you have to focus on systems that
make your work easier so if you have a
system in place then you just have to
make it happen every single day a very
concrete example in this regard or tip
is for me is ask yourself every two
months or every three months
is the resource i'm using good
at the at the time that i'm talking
because maybe something happened and as
you were saying before maybe yours your
skills are a little bit better and
something started to change am i using
the resource in a way that i like can i
tweak something can i tweak uh change
the amount of time can i change the time
that i do it so when you do it for how
long you do it how you do it and even
the resource you're using you can always
ask yourself every two months like a
check a periodic check if there's
anything that you can change because
you're in complete
charge of your learning process so every
two months every three months ask
yourself these questions write them down
and if there's anything that you want to
change do it because it's going to be
beneficial
so to combine this it's important to
have a plan it's important to have a
routine but it's also important to check
if it's working and not check every
single day because like you said it's
the same if you look into the mirror
every day you don't see yourself age but
if you look at pictures from a few years
ago you clearly see that difference so
you can see if a routine is working
every day but every month or every two
months you can check is the system that
i set on place working is it working for
me and if it's not then you tweak it and
if it's working then you just continue
with it fantastic so it's important to
have that balance it's important to
build a perspective over time to look
back in periods of three months because
we're very good at checking what happens
during the day or understanding what
happens day by day but not over long
stretches of time so this taps into a
point number three
which i think is very important is that
polyglots know what works for them and
what does not work for them in my
personal
case for example in my personal uh way
of learning languages what i do is i
check every i check what i'm doing every
two or three months and i change things
here and there and i discard some things
and i replace some some other things and
i completely change something else
what's what's what's your thinking that
what's your what's your experience
learning languages when it comes to
discarding stuff you like and keeping or
replacing or improving stuff you don't
you do like yeah so it's very similar to
what we talked about in point two that
it's important to really check if what
you're doing is still working for you
because you might have found a resource
that works really well for you then it's
a lot of fun and every day
it loses a bit of that and you don't see
that because every day it's just a
little bit but two months later suddenly
you you wake up and you think about
language learning in a very different
way it becomes tiresome and and you're
not that motivated anymore and that's
because the resources that that you have
used two months ago that you were super
enthusiastic about
they might not be the
funnest resources anymore or or the the
method the plan that you have set up
might not work completely anymore and
you have to tweak it and so it's
important to really do a reality check
like are the resources that i'm doing
like are they are they still good like
am i still learning something or did
they become too easy or did they become
too boring do the teachers that i have
is it still fun to
to speak with them or
or am i not learning anything anymore or
did the dynamic change or um can't they
teach me anything anymore so it's really
important to to to do this check but as
we talked about in point two that to not
do this check too often
i um you know
i was i was thinking uh about the fact
that for example one thing that i always
do i i know it might sound surprising to
you because assuming is a the resource
the one resource i used to
get a foundation in the language at the
beginning i never ever finish astronomy
a unit 17 around 70 maybe 75
i just tell myself this has become
boring so something that was super
exciting at the beginning you know even
the the most the simplest of dialogues
like hi my name is maria hi my name is
john it's exciting because you don't
know anything of the language but after
three months of doing this you know i
applied my biracial translation to it
then i tell myself this is boring and
when that moment happens then you have
to have to it's not an option you have
to move to something else because if i
had to continue with asthma for three
more months i would not continue
learning the language
so it's really important to have some
periodic checks i have my own system in
place so i know that after three months
or four months of doing asthma i move to
something else but keep that in mind
because having periodic checks of three
months to four months and changing the
material the way you do it when you do
it for how long it really makes a
difference i always like saying that the
way i learn language is when people ask
me about the method i have it's not a
method it's not one method but it's a
combination a series of methods that
evolve with time and it's important to
keep that in mind
and this goes a bit against human nature
because we have
that in human nature it's you need
closure you started that book you need
to finish it and that just it just
doesn't work well with with learning
languages if if you're not
making progress if you're not motivated
to continue with it anymore it's better
to stop here than to stop than to
continue a few more weeks and then lose
motivation completely so you need to
fight that urge for closure and just
just stop like even in the middle of it
i mean there are some perfectionists who
really want to finish
reading or going through the book and by
all means if you want to do that do that
but
as gabriel was pointing it out if you
feel like that book has become boring
and not effective then you should move
to
on to something else maybe you can just
quickly read the other parts without
having to go through and understand
everything but i think that you know a
few changes here and there are important
along the long long path of language
learning okay so we talked about getting
creating finding your own material we've
talked about systems focusing on systems
rather than goals
we've talked about changing these
language learning materials and it's all
great you know listening reading
exposing yourself to input and content
what about speaking what about um
polyglots what do they do to move from
input uh into the realm of output you
know what's been your experience have
you started learning a language from
scratch at the beginning and started
speaking it from day one have you waited
a little bit and how do you move from
you know doing a language learning
material input output listening and
reading to actually speaking and
producing the language
yeah so my my views evolved on that and
now i think that it's the best to
listen to a lot before starting to speak
and that's important because first of
all you need to understand how the
language works how the language sounds
because every new language has sounds
that you don't hear at the beginning but
the more you listen to it the more you
start pick up those sounds and if you
start speaking too soon then you'll
start speaking without those sounds
which means that you'll have bad
pronunciation you'll have a bad accent
and that's really difficult to correct
later down the line so it's really
important to listen to a lot to do a lot
of input comprehensible input
for as long as possible until you really
feel comfortable until you really
understand a lot until you have a
feeling for the structure for the
language and then start speaking and at
some point you'll have to start speaking
obviously
but if you already have a really strong
foundation that you built through input
then very often you start speaking
and you're surprised how many things you
can say you picked up so many phrases so
many chunks of the language and you just
start speaking and you just know things
that you didn't even know that you know
and it's it's just great because you
already start speaking from a from a
much better basis than you would if you
start speaking from day one
you have a better pronunciation and it's
just more fun and so that's why i think
it's really important to to listen to a
lot to really get a good foundation but
then at some point you need to get to
speaking and you just need to do it and
not just a few sentences here or there
but to really
look for language partners or look for
language teachers that you can spend
several hours per week speaking to to
really progress fast have you ever tried
to speak a language from day one without
listening too much
maybe a few words here and there um i'm
not sure
i'd have i i think
in the past i've started earlier than
i'm doing it now because you just you
just have the urge to start doing
something but now that i'm really
focusing on input first like really
doing comprehensible input as stephen
krashen uh always suggested suggested i
just it's just so much it's nicer you
feel more comfortable speaking and you
know
a lot of things that you're saying are
correct because you've heard native
speakers say it so many times and it's
just it's just stuck in your brain
i agree with you i generally agree with
you and this this speaking from day one
versus waiting and you know we're
opening a can of worms but
you know let's let's put it this way in
my own experience as a polygon and i've
seen it firsthand with other politics as
well
i'm getting a lot of input getting a
critical mass of input comprehensible
and compelling input does make a
difference and normally i
i don't think i've ever spoken a
language immediately i always need at
least three to six months of input
because
when you speak at the very beginning
it's a little bit stressful you know
i've done this recently with danish but
i had been learning danish uh for quite
some time and then i also on top of that
knew
how to speak swedish i knew swedish so
um i would say in general that
getting three to six months of passive
well passive you can engage in it
actively but listening
reading listening and reading at the
same time so that you can actually
understand what you're hearing is great
you build a critical mass and then when
it comes to speaking what i do and what
i recommend you do if you have the time
and the time to uh to invest in this is
that before i start talking to someone i
create a bridge between input and output
by talking to myself
and mind you talking to myself doesn't
mean to wander around the street and
talking to myself randomly as i did
before actually i actually did this
before it means now that i have a system
in place
where i have some very short uh
guidelines that allow me to
take some material that i've already
gone through i've watched a video i've
had a conversation with a tutor or i
listen to a podcast and to create a
short summary of that content by using
certain phrases that i've jotted down
this allows me to talk to myself to
expand upon some written material i have
some guidelines and i do it you know i
fit it in my schedule when i have more
time especially on saturdays when i have
a little bit more energy i do that for
10-15 minutes by standing up and going
around and i think that this is a
technique that really helps me um
starting to speak the language without
the stress of having to speak because
speaking a language foreign language for
the first time is kind of stressful
i don't know if it's stressful for you
to speak a foreign language for the
first time but i guess
you know i guess it is yeah it's always
it's your brain is on overdrive it's you
grasp all words and and sentences that
you've heard before that you learned and
it's very stressful it takes a lot of
energy you know
gavel speaks six languages i speak 14
languages even people who have
experience in language learning
it's not true that
you
learn how to speak confidently for every
language every single time you start a
new language you go through the same
stuff you go through the insecurity of
speaking you're aware of that that makes
that's what makes a difference but the
truth is when you start using the
language for the first time it's always
a little bit stressful and your mind
goes blank and you think about stuff you
look at the other person's face you
think oh my god she's thinking or he is
thinking i'm a complete dumb dumb ass
you know
so anyway uh that's it for point number
four okay
now let's talk about one thing that has
really made a difference in my life and
my life as a person in my life as a
polyglot as a language learner and that
is creating circumstances right we tend
to think that language learning is about
hitting the book so to speak but i do
believe that the bulk of my skills i've
built them through by talking to people
by experiencing things in life right so
what's what's your take on that i think
that polyglots what politics make
do differently is that they create the
circumstances through which and in which
they can make their language learning
skills thrive yeah it's we talked about
this earlier that it's really important
to
be in touch with that language all the
time and and some people
that haven't learned languages before
find
it's a hard time for them to find the
people to speak to to find opportunities
and polyglots they just find
opportunities everywhere they they go to
international parties they they watch
international tv
for instance i always like to schedule
teachers
calls with teachers where i will have
that opportunity at the specific time
slot or traveling to that country but
really think where can you get in touch
with that language be listening to it or
being speaking to someone and this is
just what drives your language skills
forward really fast and it's basically
the immersion that we've talked about
already it's surrounding yourself with a
language all the time and it's really
important to find those opportunities
all the time and there's so many
opportunities in today's world that is
globalized that has internet with where
you find lots of content where you can
connect with everybody around the world
and that's just really important and
that's what also makes the language
learning process fun is having those
opportunities and not just always
looking at it in theory in books but
rather having the opportunity to use the
language in real life because how we
learn it in school is that
we learn the theory for years and years
and years and then at some point in the
very distant future you'll have the
opportunity to speak that language
fluently but most people
know that that's not how it works you
have to always have those opportunities
and you have to always look for those
opportunities to use that language the
opportunities are here
here
and now and around the corner it's up to
you to grab them and when people say for
example oh
it's true you guys live in europe yet
sure it's true that maybe in europe it's
a little bit easier than if you live say
in australia but the reality is that
with the internet and even in in your
town there are opportunities to find
people you know i've in my life i've
figured out that
when i learn a new language then i
notice things that i hadn't noticed
before like before learning i don't know
hungarian for example i didn't notice uh
some people speaking hungarian on the
street even in rome and this goes for
every single language so whenever you
learn a new language there are so many
opportunities right there and gabriel
said something else that is really
important this is not something that oh
you just you know have fun a little bit
it's it's paramount for your language
skills to thrive that for your own brain
that you find a compelling reason
which can be for fun or just for
communication or a mirror like a
necessity that you use the language
because if you don't use it you lose it
so if you learn languages in a vacuum
for ears with books and you never create
the opportunities to speak it then your
brain is going to decide it's going to
shut down and gonna say you know what
this this is not so important it's
always about good communication with
your own brain we tend to think that you
know we're just one person but we are
it's true but we also have to find a way
to feed our brains so that the
our brains want to learn and they thrive
and one last thing i wanted to say is
that in my personal life this has been
true for every single language that i
speak well is that at a certain point of
my life after hitting the books after
doing the bi-directional translation etc
there's always a time when there's a
breaking point where
my language skills are going to
skyrocket because i met a person i found
myself in a certain situation where from
that moment on i'm gonna be speaking
that like i will be speaking that
language and using it for real
meaningful communication an example of
that is when i met my ex french
girlfriend in prague i had been
learning french at school for many years
but then i hadn't used it for five or
six years and when i met her of course
we started speaking french and
that revolutionized my french because i
started using it every single day so it
doesn't have to be love it can be
friendship it can be traveling it can be
using a language family it can be
anything but it's important to
find that one perspective that one
activity or those activities because
those are the ones that in the long run
are going to cause you to speak the
language fluently because it takes time
takes experiences i like thinking of
language learning as a timeline and as a
story that you build for yourself every
for every language you learn you have as
another story
and you have another storyline and you
have a new identity that you build on
top of the one you already have and this
is this is very important if you want to
speak a language really well okay guys
so in this video we've talked about the
five things that polygons do differently
and that allow them to learn a bunch of
languages successfully but we have also
made another video about another very
important thing and that is mindset how
polyglots think about themselves and
about the process of language learning
makes a huge difference and we have made
this video that you can watch by
clicking here somewhere on the video and
that is on gabriel's channel so check
that out because it's a very interesting
video so
that's it for now bye from me luca and
bye from
gabriel thanks and see you in the other
video bye
[Music]
[Music]
you